sept minutes et 47 secondes c'est le
temps qui restait le genou de derek
chauvine sur le coup de georges floyd le
25 mai dernier
c'est donc un procès hors normes qui
s'ouvre ce lundi à minneapolis audience
retransmise en direct avocat star dans
les deux camps les débats sont très
attendus dans cette affaire à laquelle
avait succédé l'essor mondial du
mouvement black live matters créé en
pour éviter tout débordement plusieurs
milliers de policiers et de soldats de
la garde nationale ont été mobilisées
la sécurité a également été renforcée
aux abords du tribunal
loin de l'attention de minneapolis la
famille de georges floyd se prépare à
plusieurs semaines éprouvantes mais
entend rester optimiste
on a parlé du procès on a prié pour ça
on va garder la foi on est optimiste sur
ce qui va se passer parce qu'on a une
bonne équipe derrière nous on pense
qu'on va obtenir une condamnation et
qu'on va obtenir justice la famille de
georges floyd sait que ça va être une
longue épreuve
elle envisage que ça puisse durer de
quatre à huit semaines alors cette
famille et c'est juste comme elle le dit
de se préparer au mieux à cette épreuve
et à ce procès marathon aux états unis
la mort de georges floyd lors d'une
banale interpellation avait mis en
lumière les fractures entre forces de
l'ordre et minorités raciales
d'importantes manifestations avaient
secoué les grandes villes du pays et
soulevé une vague d'indignation mondiale
dans le minnesota la mobilisation pour
la justice et pour démontrer la
responsabilité des policiers ne s'est
jamais arrêté et depuis ce week-end de
nouveaux rassemblements se sont
multipliées les policiers très toute la
ville comme si nous étions des détenus
aient eu des agents de correction
nous n'avons pas besoin d'être corrigés
nous vous surveillons et nous en avons
fini de la surveillance
j'espère que derek chauvine sera
condamné pour homicide car ce qu'il a
fait était mal nous avons vu tout ce
qu'il a fait et j'espère qu'ils ne
diront pas que georgia floyd est mort
d'une overdose
alors que le monde entier a vu des
règles chauvine agenouillé sur son cou
le procès débutera par la sélection du
jury
un moment qui s'avère déjà délicat pour
les différentes parties
avec la médiatisation planétaire de la
faire il est en effet impossible de
trouver des jurés ignorant tout du
dossier de longues discussions sont
attendus et ce dès les premières heures
du procès afin de trouver les personnes
les plus neutre possible le début des
audiences est quant à lui prévu pour le
29 mars